how you doing Bob how you doing it's all
gonna be good you're in safe hands dr.
Pitts is in in in the house yeah hi Bob
you may feel a slight pain in your chest
area don't worry it's normal and if your
balls tickle that's doable two and three
one two three
oh whoa whoa that's how we doin in
pit-a-pat time [ __ ] get out oh what
the [ __ ] are you the [ __ ] are you that
is liver ah
I'll bet they're cuddling let's not kill
high-five
no you [ __ ] don't make me slap you
I do believe this is how you hold this
is it that's how they teach you in
school isn't it I Bob just gotta ah okay
there come on baby
ah all right let's get the stomach out
hey yo yo need that [ __ ] yeah
disgusting isn't it Bob Curtis ooh come
on baby
don't you dare die on me now Bob Yolo
mode get my [ __ ] in there it said a 10x
[ __ ] end at an Italian at N what do
you want from me calm down Oh every alle
da surgery fell and is going so well
ah stop calling me Miranda I don't want
to date you desperate [ __ ] are you
ready for the insertion baby oh that's
right yeah Oh nah what the [ __ ]
don't you dare assist my insurgent what
I finger you what the [ __ ]
save
you